[Music]
all right let's go to heidi in columbus
hey heidi what's up
hi dr john rachel thanks for taking my
call you got it what's up so i have a
question um show that you did dr john
about the gas lighting i literally
listened to it and then i ran it down to
my husband and i said you have to listen
to this because
honestly it was it helped me finally
figure out the relationship problems i
have with my family um i came from a
family that honestly they gaslighted me
like everything i wanted to do they
always put me down
and now that i'm a mom of three
they're still doing it and it's to the
point where i don't know as a mom
i feel like i have to defend my kids um
and it's it's putting a whole strain on
the relationship now my husband and i
are great he's my biggest supporter
helping me through it
we live a couple hours away they came
down to visit last week and the kids
were so afraid those
older two are six and four and they're
like we can't have our hair not look
good because they'll they'll tell us it
doesn't look good if i don't have my
shirt
not wrinkled they're gonna pick on me
and
it's and they see all these comments and
i'm just sort of at the point of i
trying to set boundaries but every time
i do they just
they start screaming at us they're
yelling at us so i just don't know how
do i undo the past and then not have it
affect my kids
hey you can't undo the past the past has
happened there's a period at the end of
that sentence
and many people in your situation you
are a professional peacekeeper and you
probably have been since you were a
little girl
your job was to make sure everybody else
didn't set off
and so you
developed a superpower of taking your
feelings and shoving them as far down as
possible and when you do that you
internalize their feelings and you
become the regulator for their feelings
and any negative feelings they have they
blame it on you am i right
oh yeah okay
so
there is no unwinding that that happened
there's a period at the end of that
sentence and any amount of energy you
spend trying to go edit that sentence
that's already been written is is energy
or taken away from your husband energy
you're taking away from your kids and
energy you're taking away from yourself
it's a waste of time don't do it
what i want you to do is to take the
word family off for a second
and i want you to think of a neighbor
who just walked by your house every
morning and then came into your home
to inspect the clothing and haircuts of
you and your kids
how long would you put up with that
not one time
yeah exactly one time and you call the
police your husband probably go to jail
right and you'd have to figure it out
your family
is hurting your children
your family's hurting you
your family's hurting your marriage
there's no negotiating with this it ends
today
and
when you put a boundary you haven't been
putting up boundaries you've been
putting up like mean thoughts
because you've just been thinking mean
things you have imaginary conversations
with them in the shower right where i'm
gonna tell them and you never actually
do
right are you hint around it am i right
oh yeah yes
it stops today and here's what a
boundary is
you're not welcome in my home anymore or
hey we're all coming down this weekend
no thank you
we already have family plans um
we'll we'll holler back at you
i don't owe you an explanation
i don't owe you a why and when they
start yelling at you here's the coolest
thing um it's not on every phone but my
phone has this feature called off
i just hang it up
can i ask a question you can okay if
she's never communicated i'm assuming
that heidi so correct me if i'm wrong
but if she's never communicated you
can't talk to us that way would you give
them a ch would you would you have a
conversation and say
here's here's the boundary
here are the comments and be very
specific these types of comments and
more anything along these lines
and if you
cross that boundary and you say that you
are never welcome like
for my dad and your dad my mom and your
mom yes
because i believe that my mom and my dad
and your mom and your dad truly love us
and they often give us advice
that's their way of telling us they love
us
tell me if i'm wrong here heidi but this
sounds like your family's predatory
yeah yeah okay
they don't
suddenly they don't want to hear if
there's anything wrong it's always like
well that's your fault okay okay my
animals are totally different story you
could sit them down and they would want
to make that change okay all right there
you go it's so sorry
it's hard you're gonna have to grieve it
because this isn't what you wanted you
wanted grandkids and grandparents and
christmases
and it's not gonna happen
so be sad be real sad grieve the heck
out of it and protect your heart and
your kids and your marriage